he he wrote the high-performance browser
networking book for a Riley which is
also available for free and the links on
his website if the internet is a series
of tubes then this is one of the world's
greatest plumbers hands together for
ilya Grigori all right thanks Jake all
right so we're going to talk about a
little bit about optimizing network
performance and specifically some of the
things that we've been doing on the
chrome team for helping deliver better
apps and I guess the first thing that we
should ask is doesn't matter all right
what's the problem that we're trying to
solve and Tony gentle Corp is actually
somewhere here in the room run a number
of different tests over the last couple
of months where he's been kind of deep
diving into where do we spend our time
like when we try to render a web page
what are the bottlenecks today and
here's a series of these posts and
blinged-out if you guys are interested
in kind of low level guts of how blink
works and then chrome kind of end-to-end
but wants us to me stood out in
particular and this is a test where we
took the top 1 million alexis ice and
just random to chrome and looked at
where do we spend our time like
internally the actual main blink red
where is the time going and the big
takeaway here is that said approximately
seventy percent of the time we're just
basically idling on the network right
that's that big chunk right here in the
blue and then after that you you have
all of your usual offenders things like
well we gotta execute a JavaScript we
gotta paint pixels in all the rest to do
layouts so this should not be surprising
right this is specifically for the first
page load there's a very different
profile of course once the page is
loaded and you're interacting with the
page that's a different problem but this
in part is one big problem that we're
trying to solve right like how do we
make this blue part smaller or just go
faster so there's two takeaways that you
can take from this one is page loads and
network are a problem right that's
seventy percent of loading the page
today but the good news is that if we
can do anything to the network stack in
terms of improving that latency
improving performance it's going to have
a significant impact on how we
experience the web so even small
fractional wins in the space will in
fact have a huge performance impact
so kind of with that in mind what I
wanted to do is actually take a look at
some of the things that we've been
working on internally in Chrome's is
kind of looking under the hood this is
not perhaps something that you would be
as a developer looking at api's or
trying to figure out how to optimize
this is the kind of stuff that chrome
does internally but we have a very
dedicated and awesome performance team
working on the stuff and I wanted to
highlight some of the winds that we had
over the last year and also kind of such
that you know what we're working on and
also highlight the potential areas for
improvement in the future and after that
we're going to look at some of the new
additions specifically kind of low-level
Network plumbing stuff that we support
in chrome so things like speedy some
knows about quick and other things and
then finally we talked about measurement
right of course performance is a big
theme throughout this entire event and
we want to make sure that we give you
the tools to measure performance in the
best way possible right you should be
much you should be able to measure
anything you need in the stack so first
let's actually do a quick survey this is
going to be kind of all over the map but
I want to highlight a few things first
and chrome 26 we lon we landed the new
asynchronous DNS resolver which is kind
of low level plumbing stuff so we're not
no longer relying on the operating
system dns resolver we actually have our
own this is available on today it's
available on windows mac and chrome OS
so this is not yet on mobile hopefully
it will be so why do we why don't we
want to do this well first of all it
gives us a lot more control we can do a
lot smarter strategies for how we
resolve names and other things and here
are some numbers performance numbers in
terms of what we've seen based on the
since we've landed m26 it took us a
couple of tries to actually kind of get
the performance numbers as good as they
are but you can see that there's
significant winds across the board and
for things like Chrome OS we've reduced
the dns resolution time significantly
thirty-six percent and not only that but
we're also measuring the resolve plus
CCP connect and you can see that it's
you know their winds across the board
and of course some of these are
platform-specific some platforms just do
a better job of implementing their dns
resolvers in a first
but the cool thing is that we can
actually now kind of take control now
that we've got the basic plumbing
working we can take control and do
smarter things so for example we can
race different resolutions for ipv6 and
ipv4 we are now actually doing adapt
retries so we actually remember which
the NS servers we've used so we can do a
better job of making these resolutions
faster in the future and this is
definitely a space for a lot of
improvement and also kind of you know
subtle things like providing better use
user error pages right before we would
just get a failed timeout from the dns
resolution and we just kind of like we
give up we have no idea we can give any
useful feedback to the user now we can
go much much further so that's pretty
cool moving on in m27 we landed this big
and important improvement which is we
completely rewrote how we schedule
resources right it's one thing for us to
get the HTML bytes we then discover the
resources and then we need to figure out
how do we schedule them efficiently on
the wire like we care about JavaScript
before images and and other things and
the big change that we've done in there
in EM 27 is we replace that scheduler
and we also started focusing on
perceived performance so instead of just
measuring the page load time we started
measuring things like speed index so
what kind of optimizations we can do in
resource scheduler to improve speed
index in fact you know we've made
decisions where we've intentionally
chosen speed index over page load time
or on load so there are changes that
have gone in where we regressed in some
cases on load time but we've improved
speed index because we think that
perceived performance getting useful
pixels on the screen is a win for the
user and one interesting take away from
this work that was done and I'm 27 was
that we realized that a lot of pages
were actually competing for bandwidth
unnecessarily so they were trying to
download too many things we've gotten so
good at charting our assets that it's
actually backfiring on a lot of sites so
in particular one big interesting change
that when in in that iteration was that
the new scheduler would only down
what up to 10 images in parallel so for
example if you have a gallery of images
you have let's say 30 of them on a page
and you shorten them you know in 20
different ways we would not open more
than 10 connections at once because we
found that that actually hurts
performance in most cases so you know if
you're developing your site today chrome
will limit you to 10 image downloads but
in other browsers you also have the
problem I'm not sure what exact schedule
a scheduling algorithms they're using
but perhaps something you should
consider on your site right there is
such thing as over starting your site
later in am 28 speaking of perceived
performance we've also improved the
speedy performance quite a bit so that
the change here is actually pretty
awesome and pretty trivial in that now
that we have control over the resource
scheduler we said look if you're using
speedy we have a much better way to
schedule resources which as we know the
priority we can send that priority to
the server the server can do the right
thing so we won't delay any resource
scheduling on the client which is kind
of looks like fake latency or not fake
unnecessary latency that were otherwise
introducing so if you're using speedy
this is a nice performance one because
it allows us once again get those pixels
earlier visible earlier on the screen so
if you haven't already I definitely
encourage you to look into playing with
speedy so here using apache you can
somewhat speedy and genetics and other
servers supported as well and actually
welcome back to speedy a little bit
later in m30 there's been more yet more
improvements to the resource scheduler
we keep improving and iterating on all
of these different strategies a one
interesting kind of take away that we
had in this iteration was that we
actually started distinguishing between
optimizing for site the popular sites
versus sites in the tail right there's
different ways that sites are
constructed in terms of kind of patterns
that they use how they lay out the
resources and all the rest and this
change or this iteration in particular
actually helped quite a bit in terms of
accelerating the sites in a long tail
and you think about a ten percent
improvement and firing the onload right
this is just like one chrome litter
ation
revision is huge right like that's
that's a ten percent when an onload and
nine percent improvement in speed index
so there's just faster pixels on the
screen so these are impressive numbers
and I think what's most exciting for me
is if we look forward you know based on
the work that we have in the pipeline
now and project that a little bit we see
you know significant improvements that
we can still make to these algorithms so
right now at least based on current code
that we have you can expect more wins
rolling out to our users so this is
great like this is as far as I'm
concerned this is free performance right
like the apps it's the same apps they're
just rendering faster because we're
doing a better job of how we schedule
those resources in chrome so that's
that's pretty exciting another huge huge
win that's coming and that that's
available at on Android today is what
we're calling the simple cash so one of
the problems that we realize that we had
on Android and mobile phones in
particular is that in order for us to do
dispatch to dispatch a network request
we actually had to do a number of
different context switches like we would
go from the main thread so on io thread
to we do another jump we would always do
a check on the file system which in
itself can take quite a bit of time and
the idea behind simple caches to try to
simplify that as the name implies to the
extent that we can and ideally avoid any
context switches on going to disk so
that should help quite a bit in terms of
the actual performance of the simple
cash and here's some early numbers these
look very very good the blue line on the
bottom is the original and what you see
here is the latency right so he kind of
had this like long tail distribution
where basically every request incurred a
minimum of several milliseconds but then
you have this long tail where it wasn't
a typical for a request to take 50
milliseconds right before we could even
dispatch it because we have to kind of
do a couple of thread hops and then
check disk or check flash in this case
and kind of bubble that back up with a
new simple cash basically we can just
complete it immediately most of the
requests every once in a while you know
we still have some delays but
it's the this is no type of line where
you want to see on all of your
performance charts and this is quite
amazing because once we have the simple
cash this is based on our measurements
this has improved all HTTP transfers the
speed of these transfers in terms of the
time from the first request bite that we
want to send to completion by ten
percent which you think about it is
massive right and not only that but in
m31 we're seeing seven percent page load
time improvement so this is simply
eliminating that extra latency at the
beginning of each and every request and
once again there is more work going into
m32 and we hope that we can improve this
even further so this is this is huge and
this isn't be a an awesome when for
mobile browsers and then finally one of
the last things that we started
iterating towards the end of the year
here and something that I'm really
really excited about is focusing on
improving the speculative optimizations
that we already doing chrome we do a lot
of speculative optimization as it is
today but now we're also looking at how
do we refine these how do we expose the
right primitives and how do we make
better use of them one example is
something like a prefetch right so if
you're familiar with a link rel prefetch
what allows you to say is hey I will
need this resource perhaps on the next
page that could be an HTML page that
could be a CSS file and image what have
you right please fetch this for me such
that I don't have to fetch that or i can
just fetch it out of the cash when the
user initiates that load one of the
gotchas there was if that requests did
not complete in time for the next
navigation you would get cancelled so
you kind of incurred a double download
and it like it just didn't make sense so
for example we have this new patch
that's that's in its not available in
Canary yet but it's coming soon called
detachable prefetch which will actually
keep the prefetch alive even as you
navigate away such that you can still
make use of that resource once you get
to your destination so that's pretty
awesome and this will also apply to
other things like pre renders and other
types of improvements so this is pretty
cool and this is how it basically it
looks chrome allows you to actually
dynamically create these hints so for
example if let's say the user initiates
some sort of an act
like they click on the checkout button
or they click on add to cart button and
you know that they're going to go to the
checkout page at that moment you can
actually inject one of these link
elements and say hey I would like you to
prefetch that asset for me because now i
know i will need it and vice versa you
can actually delete this element out of
the other the dom and we will cancel the
prefetch as well so you can dynamically
script how in basically drive chrome to
do these pre fetches for you so this
pretty cool stuff and i think this is a
place where we can do a lot more in the
future as well so that's a little bit
about kind of the low level guts and
improvements in chrome now let's take a
look at some of the protocols that we've
been working on so back in 2009 roughly
actually four years ago almost on a dot
we announced our work on speedy or
initial efforts around speedy and since
then we've gone I think quite a long way
we've had several iterations of the
protocol itself so be to v3 3.1 now
we're working on version 4 and that
actually became the foundation of HTTP
to which is pretty exciting and HP to
work in itself is progressing quite
rapidly and I'm really excited about
that so today we actually have both
speedy in HP to support in Chrome
although HP to is under a flag but it is
there it's something that we're
iterating on and then once HTTP to I
know this is a common question once hp2
is marked as ready as a standard we will
just switch over to http too so speed
think of speedy as kind of like an
experimental ground for us to try
different ideas and feed them back into
the HTTP to spec rights like it'd be
great if we had this feature let's go
and try and implement that future we try
it we discover the rough edges and then
we kind of feed that back into HTTP two
so earlier in the year we actually
deployed speedy 3.1 across all of our
google servers and of course added
support in chrome firefox also supports
speedy 3.1 and here are some numbers
we've actually we've never released as
before but these are the performance
numbers that we see for speedy across
some of the major Google properties and
these are consistent across all the
different Google Sites so you
kind of looking at the right order of
magnitude anywhere between twenty to
forty to fifty percent improvement in
latency as compared to HTTPS and in some
cases were actually so this even despite
the fact that we have these extra
handshake round trips and all the rest
and CLS oftentimes we actually end up
going faster than just vanilla HTTP as
well which is of course the point of
this whole exercise to begin with so
this is really exciting and I guess the
important bit here is also that not only
is it helping the median which is of
course we'd like to see but it's also
consistently helping all of our users
the ones on fast connections and
especially so for the ones that are in
the slow connections are the ones with
the hierarchy tee times which is
especially relevant for things like
mobile right where our tee tees are
definitely higher so this is really
exciting this was very promising and I
hope that this will help kind of drive
the HP to adoption as well so you know
if you haven't looked at speedy I
definitely encourage you to do so there
are modules for virtually every popular
server out there today that you can
enable and just play with a neighborhood
I enable it on your site and there's
also also commercial support for it as
well so you know f5 Akamai and others
support speedy so that's that's pretty
cool and as I mentioned we also do have
HP too if you're if you're curious if
you want to play with it we do have HP
to support under flag so you can
actually enable that and then you know
run it against your local server I think
the only big public site that supports
HTTP to today is twitter com so in
theory you can you can test it on that
but there are also open source servers
that speak HP today that you can play
with so speedy is kind of a production
version if you will HP two is coming
soon and hopefully in fingers crossed
sometime in 2014 so that's speedy you
may have caught the wind of some other
protocol that we started working on
earlier in the year which is quick which
is quick UDP internet connections and
the idea here is actually to kind of
take what we've done with speedy and go
one step beyond and this was actually
our intent right
the very beginning when we started
thinking of speedy but it was just too
much of a leap to change both the
protocol kind of the application
protocol and the transport protocol so
it kind of decoupled those and quick is
basically that we're trying to go one
step further and say well could we
rebuild or could we build a better
transport for HTTP traffic period on top
of UDP could we experiment with new
ideas some of the and you know the core
premise of the stuff is it's all about
latency we're trying to eliminate
latency everywhere we can so can we
eliminate extra round trips to establish
the secure tunnel can we do better
congestion control what if we do packet
pacing what if we do forward error
correction what can we do to innovate in
the space to help produce the page load
times on the web and there's a lot of
interesting ideas if you guys are
curious about this kind of stuff we've
posted our design docs and it's a very
long dock I encourage you to read it and
give us feedback we have a Google Group
for that and this question comes up
quite frequently which is like what
what's the point like what are you
trying to do here and the answer is very
simple we just want to make faster
internet for for everybody to use and
there are two ways that this will happen
one is we end up building a really
awesome protocol that everybody loves
and we take it to ITF and just like with
HP too and speedy you know we work with
the community and kind of make that the
standard that's plausible and maybe that
will happen the alternative route is we
just experiment with quick we experiment
with different ideas and those ideas get
adopted you know the good ones get
adopted into existing protocol stacks
like TCP and TLS and actually we're
already seeing some of that we're based
on our experience with the encryption
stuff and quick the TLS working group is
looking at improvements in terms of can
we eliminate some extra round trips so
in either case the point is no matter
which one of these happens the users
will win will get faster internet and
that's that's our intent with quick so
that's pretty awesome we don't have any
benchmarks for it as of today we're
still at a point where we want to make
sure that it works and it works
correctly before we start optimizing
kind of all the all the edges around it
but you can
actually play with quick today we
haven't deployed on Google servers and
you can also enable it if you go into
Chrome flags you can flip quick support
and then you can for example access
YouTube and you'll get served youtube
com or other Google service over UDP
over quick and you if you're curious you
can dive into Chrome net internals and
kind of look at the actual protocol and
all this other stuff so you know if
you're into kind of low-level networking
protocols definitely a thing you want to
check out and play with there's lots of
interesting ideas in the protocol
alright shifting gears line is mentioned
chrome data compression this is
something that we launched earlier in
the year as you heard it provides
roughly fifty percent data savings
that's kind of the average number for a
lot of users turns out there's a lot of
poorly compressed content on the web
people still forget to gzip their their
content which is one of the
optimizations that we apply for texts
like assets and we also convert all the
images to FP which provides a
significant savings so this is a big
benefits a lot of users but one thing
that Linus didn't mention is that there
are other and secondary benefits to that
because we run over speedy so between
your phone and a Google server it's
actually a speedy connection it's an
encrypted connection so I actually use
Chrome data compression in part for the
data compression part but also partially
to secure my browsing because when I
enable this the secure traffic if you're
connecting to your bank for example in
htps site it will go directly to the
site so that traffic is encrypted but
you're trying to connect to some
unencrypted site it'll just flow
basically you know as it is on the wire
with chrome data compression and that
goes through a secure tunnel so even if
you're on I don't know starbucks Wi-Fi
or whatever some some unencrypted Wi-Fi
and you're browsing around all of your
data is encrypted so that's that's
really nice and maybe one important
thing to highlight with chrome data
compression is it is still the full
fidelity html5 web experience right
we're not doing anything to modify your
site we're not trying to render it on
the server we're not like you have all
the flexibility of JavaScript CSS and
older
on on your phone that's where the code
gets executed so we're just modifying
and optimizing some of the assets as
they get delivered some common questions
that I get but chrome data compression
something you should know is you know
this is going through a proxy so if
you're developing a site where you're
relying on geoip functionality to
customize the location to the user or
maybe serve relevant ads you should be
looking for the ex forward for header
which is the IP address of of the client
as forwarded by the chrome data proxy
and similarly if for whatever reason you
absolutely want to make sure that you
know we don't do anything to your
content you can actually opt out on a
per resource basis if you add an o
transform header it basically tells
chrome data proxy to just be hands-off
with that resource so we won't react
amaizing or we won't recompress that
text or other things so these are these
are standard kind of proxy proxy
directives chrome data compression proxy
is supports it so just an FYI shifting
gears websockets this is really really
exciting do you have any WebSocket
developers in the room yes awesome so
WebSocket compression is going to be
live in m32 which is a long-overdue
feature like one of the gotchas with
WebSockets was that you could transfer
binary and text but text would always go
as uncompressed in both directions now
that we have the spec up to date and we
already have the code in chrome you can
actually negotiate the deflate
compression to apply in both directions
and the server can selectively compress
any given frame and a client or as of
today chrome will compress every single
frame going going out from your mobile
device or from your desktop device and
I'm not going to go into details here
but we also actually the spec provides a
number of different parameters to
customize how the compression will be
done for example the size of the sliding
windows such that you can control the
resources used on your server and on
your client plus some other flags so
this is really really exciting because
the
definitely been a sore point for for web
sockets we heard about WebRTC and data
channel the way I think about data
channel is basically WebSocket but over
UDP and p2p right so we can communicate
directly between devices we don't have
to go through an intermediary like like
a server and data channel and m31 has
now officially switched to sctp protocol
so previously we're using we were using
RTP data channels and you know that was
the reason for some of the
incompatibilities with some of the other
vendors but as of m31 sctp is the
default and we will aggressively remove
support for RTP data channels so if
you're using data channels today this is
something you want to revisit and if
you're not familiar with data channels I
encourage you to check out the link so
i'll post the slides later for you know
how this works and why this is awesome
because it allows you to define things
like fire-and-forget semantics you know
don't retransmits oh it's a really nice
transport for doing low latency data
exchange and then finally let's talk
about measurement right so there's a lot
of kind of protocol improvements that
are going on but as we know we need to
be able to measure things in order to
improve them so of course we're all
familiar with navigation timing or I
hope we are most people here expect
would be you can get detailed low-level
stats about how long that each
connection take in terms of DNS time TSP
time and all the other things you can
throw that into your analytics solution
here i'm showing you google analytics
which allows you to segment this data to
say well I want to look at my mobile
users versus desktop you can segment it
by any other variable you define like
has a user click the checkout button or
they registered etc this was all great
the one got you with this is this is
only for the main page right what about
the other 85 resources or 100 resources
that you have on your page how are those
performing well in chrome we have
support for resource timing which gives
you that same level of access to all of
the network metadata or timestamps I
should say on a per resource basis so
you can see here that you can actually
query for a specific resource like your
javascript file that you're loading
maybe you're loading it from CDN and
you're wondering how well is my CD and
performing you can get your real user
measurement data for that specific
resource and then look up the time for
dns tcp connect time total transfer time
etc the only thing that you need to be
aware of is that the resource has to
manually opt-in and allow the data to be
gathered to begin with this is done for
privacy reasons to make sure that you
know somebody can just kind of iterate
over your cash and figure out where
where you've been in the past or
something like it so you just for your
own resources you need to add this
header and then if you're using
third-party resources if that origin is
already not providing this header then
you should ask them to do so because you
know here's one example where I have a
web font on my site web fonts have
weapons delay when the tech gets painted
so the question is how's in this case
this is the google city and how's google
sitting and performing in terms of
serving the actual font is it hurting my
users well now i can actually grab that
data from research time you just as i
showed you a few slides ago and we can
just pump that into google analytics
here you can see that i'm tracking the
dns tcp and transfer times and it turns
out that my fonts the fonts coming from
Google CDN at least for my site are
being loaded in this case within 150
milliseconds which to me was an
acceptable time and that was that was
fine for me but you can now think about
using this sort of data to define third
party SL is right you rely on
third-party widgets you can say well
your widgets must load in X amount of
time etc you can actually track this
with resource timing which is pretty
awesome so as a quick recap we covered a
lot of ground there's a new dns resolver
in chrome which is you know double-digit
performance improvement in actual dns
resolutions and the new scheduler is
definitely something we're really
excited about we're already seeing huge
improvements there ten and twenty
percent improvement in actual speed
index and page load times the simple
cash stuff is a huge went on mobile and
i'm really excited to have that out
there and then you know moving forward
I'm hoping that we can make the pre
resolve and prefetch
a pre-rendered stuff much much smarter
and you saw the speedy ones right so all
of these things are incremental right
ten percent here twenty percent there
before you know it you're actually
saving hundreds of milliseconds and
sometimes seconds for the user which is
a huge one and some of these things you
guys need to optimize for you know these
are the things where you need to install
speedy and you configure speeding to
make sure that your stacks are
configured correctly and in other cases
it's just also doing a better job of
scheduling this kind of stuff and then
finally you know if you haven't already
I definitely encourage you to look at
things like NAFTA I mean user timing and
resource timing so I talked about
resource timing user timing allows you
to measure any chunk of code and just
get high resolution time stamps for you
know this is one I started this is going
to end it and be can come back to your
server so all of these things are
supported in chrome and you know what
you can measure you can optimize so with
that I'll leave you the link to the
slides thank you